Start off by proving that Muhammad is
greater.
>> No, no, no, no. I meant to talk about
Paul. I'm to talk about Muhammad. I talk
about
>> I'm sorry. That's the topic.
>> Yeah. Than Paul.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, and you was asked about
Paul and why you think he's so great and
you reeled of so many things. So, I'm
here to contest that.
>> That was in line of people giving
reasons why they think Muhammad is
greater than Paul.
>> No, no. I'm here to contest Paul. M. I'm
I'm I'm trying to understand why you
think Paul's such a great authority. You
said he's you think he's reliable,
trustworthy,
>> all of these things. So I'm I'm here to
challenge that. I'm Well, if if Paul's
dismissed, there's nothing to challenge
Muhammad, is there? Okay. So just I can
I can dismiss Muhammad, too. So what?
>> Yeah, but you you said Paul So your
claim is Paul is greater. So
>> that's not my claim. My claim is prove
Muhammad is greater than Paul. Or not.
That's not even my claim. It's my
challenge. Prove Muhammad is greater
than Paul. That's what
>> So I'm Is that what your title is? Yes,
bro. Prove Muhammad is greater than
Paul.
>> So, all I've heard you so far is when
you was asked, "Why do you think Paul's
so great?" And you listed it listed so
many things, which are just not true.
So, this is why I'm interested in
dealing with because I don't think you
have a clue when it comes to Paul. I
really really don't. You're obsessed
with Islam, but you you don't know your
own religion. I don't believe.
>> Cool. Cool beans. So, let's do it how
everybody has to start off. You have to
start off cuz I'm telling you right now,
Hamza, and you might not like this, but
this is how it is. You have to prove how
Muhammad is greater than Paul. Both of
them right now are on the scales. You
have to give your reasonings and we're
going to see if they stand.
>> We can't prove anything either way. You
can believe it. You can't prove it.
>> Okay. So, how about this? Let's rephrase
it. What is your evidence that Paul, I'm
sorry, that Muhammad is greater than
Paul. What's your evidence?
>> Uh Muhammad was a messenger of God.
>> What makes him a messenger and not Paul?
>> I don't think Paul received revelation.
First thing, I don't think he was in
line with the teachings of what he
claimed. I don't believe he was a
Pharisee.
>> All right, let's do one thing at a time.
One thing at a time.
>> All right, I'll make it easy. Paul was a
liar. Muhammad wasn't.
>> What? Okay. One thing at a time. Let's
start with the first thing. You said
that you don't believe that Paul
received revelation.
>> No, no. Let's start from the beginning.
>> Believe Muhammad did.
>> Let's make it simple.
>> That's the first thing you said.
>> No, no, no. But let me let me nutshell
it for you.
>> No, I don't need I don't need
>> No. This right here, we're doing one
thing.
>> No, no. I'll make it easy. Paul's a
liar.
>> That That's fine. That's point four.
That's point4.
>> No, no, no. No, no, no, no. One rolls
into all of them.
>> Paul's a liar. Muhammad isn't.
>> I got you. I got you. So, what makes you
believe Muhammad received revelation
over Paul receiving revelation?
>> Because Paul's a liar.
>> Okay. So, what makes you think he lied
about his him receiving revelation?
>> Because why? Because of what he received
based upon your text and what the
disciples believed was contrary.
>> All right. So, just to be clear, you're
saying that because Paul and what he
supposedly received is contrary to what
the apostles had, then that would make
Paul a liar. Yes.
>> Okay. So, for somebody to be to be a
true messenger, to have credibility,
>> they would have to be in line with the
apostles. Is that correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Was Muhammad in line with the
apostles?
>> That Please don't do that nonsense.
>> That's what we're doing.
>> Don't do that nonsense.
>> It's no It's no double standard.
>> No double standards.
>> No. The thing is, you see, we're talking
about your text, your position.
I'm not playing this game. I don't
answer questions to Christians until you
demonstrate you understand English,
comprehend it, utilize it.
>> The point here is this. You made so many
claims about Paul, which went
unchallenged.
>> I'm sorry, your grace. Forgive my
insulence. Unfortunately, we do have a
subject matter that we have going on.
>> Why Why is it when other people question
you on Paul,
>> your grace, please, my forgive my
insulence, but again,
>> I'm going to go play Balot later, dude.
[laughter]
>> Come on. I'm
>> see you later, dude.
>> Take care.
I I I I watched you go unchallenged with
your claims about Paul and as soon as
you're challenged on Paul, I knew you're
going to run like a little girl to I
did. I'm hand.
You can't take the smoke.
>> I'm I'm right here. Look who answer
questions about Paul then which you've
been going.
>> As soon as you're pressed on Paul, you
know you're clueless.
>> You seem so you run to Islam and all
this.
>> You seem upset.
>> Focus on Paul. Validate. Oh, listen.
I'll explain why. Let me explain
something.
>> Please, don't talk about Muhammad.
Please don't let me explain my own
stand. Let me explain it to you. I don't
need to explain I don't need you to
explain anything to me, man.
>> Well, I'm going to like this.
>> Well, I'm going to when you come here,
>> so my argument against Paul destroys
>> Let's go ahead and do this. When you
come here and you try to challenge me on
my subject, you're going to get treated
like everybody, Hamza. Everybody, bro,
stop trying to run away from the
challenge. Stop. You're you're not going
to get away with double standards here.
So if you're going to say and and you
see how you cut yourself. You said that
if somebody does not agree with the
apostles then therefore they are a liar.
Now answer the question. Did Muhammad
agree with the apostles? Answer.
>> It will help you. It will help you.
Yeah. You'll mute me. [laughter]
>> Who are you? You've been unchallenged in
your claims about Paul. And as soon as
you're pressed on to the next,
>> your audience can see you can't defend
Paul. You're clueless, mate.
>> Yeah, I steamroll Christians all day on
Paul. I wanted a challenge and and you
can't
>> take care of yourself now.
>> Watch your head, man. Watch your head on
the way out, big dog. This is weird. I
I'm I'm a little lost. I I I'm confused.
I could have sworn. Does it say God God
logic's den? I could have sworn it was
it was it was forgive my insulence, your
grace. Um, forgive me uh my insulence
again, your grace, your highness.
Unfortunately, we had a topic and and
forgive me again. I asked you a question
that immediately
exposed your argument immediately. Do
you guys I want you guys to see this and
you guys all saw it. This dude fell for
the same trap that every common Muslim
falls for. Every common Muslim, which is
every Muslim, big Dawa dude supposed to
come in here and know how to debate and
know how to maneuver and Hamza's den
came in and fell for the same trap. Paul
is a liar because he disagreed with the
apostles. So, whoever is not in line
with the apostles is a liar, Hamza.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I would say that.
Yeah. Yeah, mate. Yeah. Okay. Awesome.
Did was Muhammad in line with the
apostles? Oh, no. [clears throat] I'm
not doing that, mate. Not doing that,
mate. Why not? No.
Def def defend defend your Paul, man.
Defend your Bible. Yeah, bro. We are
defending Paul by showing you how your
accusations against Paul actually work
against Muhammad, not Paul. You have a
double standard that you cannot defend.
That was way too easy.